-We are hanging out
with Cate Blanchett!
Aw, we love you so much!
Come on.
Her new movie, "Ocean's 8,"
is in theaters on June 8th.
Cate and I are about to go
head-to-head
in a game of
egg Russian roulette.
Higgins, would you like to
explain how this works?
-Yes, James!
[ Laughter ]
In my hand,
I have one dozen eggs.
Eight of them are boiled!
And four of them are still raw.
You and Cate will take turns
selecting one egg at a time
and smashing them upon the top
of your head.
You won't know which eggs are
raw and which are hard-boiled.
[ Cackles ]
Once you chose an egg,
you must smash it!
No put-backs.
-Okay.
-First one to smash two raw eggs
on the head loses.
-I have to get on a plane
right after this.
-No! Oh, perfect.
-Well, then, good luck.
-Nothing like being pat
with egg on your head.
-Buena fortuna, Cate.
You choose the first egg.
-Okay, anyone?
Anyone from the audience?
Should I chose this one?
[ Audience shouting ]
No? Or this one?
That one?
-Don't tap them.
All right, good, that's --
-Good luck!
-What do I do, Jimmy?
What do I do?
-Just smash it.
Just smash it and have faith.
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
-It still hurt. It still hurt.
-It still hurts.
All right, you can put that --
-Okay.
-All right, here we go.
-I don't eat it?
-No, you don't eat it, no.
-Oh, my God, it smells.
[ Audience shouting ]
-The white one?
Thank you, the white one.
-The white one!
-I already can tell
it's hard-boiled.
It's great.
This game is so easy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, choose one.
-Be it on your head,
servicemen and women.
-Here you go. This is it.
How's it feel? You feeling good?
You feeling confident?
Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
It's getting egg-citing!
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience shouting ]
-That gentlemen over there
seems extremely confident.
-Hoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, guys!
-Thank you to the gentlemen
in the glasses.
-This happening. It's happening!
One of these -- there are four
raw ones in there.
Oh, my God, please stop handling
the eggs like that. Please.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience shouting ]
-Why would you aim it
at my head?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh, I got to start hitting
them in a different place.
-Really? Are you starting to --
-Yeah.
-Are you starting
to break the skin?
-Yeah. I'm gonna sue.
-Okay.
-Oh, oh, oh!
♪♪♪♪
-I love having you on.
Congrats on the new movie!
It's gonna be a big success!
[ Audience oohs ]
-I guess the yolks on you!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
This one?
[ Audience shouting ]
I think you have betrayed me.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey.
-Oh, my gosh, this is insane.
They're not even helping me
anymore -- there's no one.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Loser!
-No way, man! No way!
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Dinging ]
The winner -- the champion,
Cate Blanchett, everyone.